and we have this shot right here what is
this
this is this is your uh can i say
already
this is your 108 megapixels right here
what hey guys it's max and vadim
and today we have another blind camera
comparison
but this time we're stepping it up we
know that the s21 ultra takes
amazing photos even has 8k video and
it's the best camera phone on the market
but sony just released this brand new a1
it shoots 8k video has super high
resolution stills
and this camera along with the lenses
that i needed to compete with s21
cost 9 500 so today we're gonna see
can we tell the difference are the
photos a lot better
or should you just use a smartphone yep
so what max did is he took a bunch of
photos with
both of them and what i have right here
is a piece of paper so i'm gonna be
voting
i've never seen any of these photos
before i have no idea which one is which
so this is gonna be extremely
interesting so you guys grab a piece of
paper and a pen
please go along with us and max is
actually gonna vote i'm gonna vote two i
know which one is which for a lot of
these
but i'm not gonna say anything until
vadim vote so do it this is our first
image
108 megapixels on one 50 on the other
so this one's been visible to me for a
while so i can definitely see that there
is
more sharpness more detail on the left
like by far
if you look on the right image it's just
soft
everywhere you know like even especially
in the trees way back there so i think i
like the left but
i don't know it looks good i agree it's
good i also i like this because you see
a lot more of the sky
yeah and this is brighter so let's move
what
s21 ultra wait a minute which this this
[ __ ] was this out of focus
no it was it's it's in focus wow um 108
megapixels
it's actually you get more detail it is
a little over sharp and you were right
yeah
but smartphones are great at dynamic
range that's why we get a little bit
more blue sky a little bit more detail
it's stacking all those images it's
impressive
where the sony isn't so wow s21
next photo here
okay uh man this is in i mean
this is just too blown out you know like
the sky is too blown out i like the
colors i like everything
uh the exposure of his face is really
nice this is both with
uh the camera doing facial exposures
both smartphone and camera can do this
i mean i i'm still going with the right
i don't know i'm still going to go with
the right just because
it's not super blown out and like i
don't know
that's true you have all this detail
this is all blown out here i'm going
with the left
i don't like this flatness here i focus
on the face
even though i wish we had better dynamic
range it's killed and this one is not a
rock photo
you could shoot raw i did chew on some
of these
all right sony one
it's for me you get the s21
these beautiful pastries at this local
bakery
okay which one would you want to eat
i have to say i'm shocked how similar
these are yeah they're extremely
the portrait mode on here oh my goodness
extremely similar there's so much
depth of field here i don't know man i
feel like i'm gonna go with
the one on the right just because like
these croissants you see all that
texture and detail there i kind of like
that
and just because they're so similar but
this one looks a little bit flat
i'm gonna go with the right okay it's
hot i would take any one of these
but i think you're right this one has a
little bit too much blur
yeah it's kind of but still
i i'm just shocked how good the s21 did
it's close
doing all this blur yeah yeah depth of
field and
time for a tougher scenario with this
little statue at in coeur d'alene
i think i'm gonna go with the one on the
left definitely looks nice it looks like
the blur edging of his hat got
messed up there and i think there's
quite a bit more detail
and like the colors i don't know i like
the colors in white balance better
it turned out better on the left i agree
a1 again a1 again and yeah real blur
versus fake you got all those little
issues there and a little bit
overexposed
all right this is another portrait shot
uh
inside of a coffee bar and i honestly i
don't actually don't know which one is
which here
wow that's so close i'm trying to guess
i'm just so remembered
i'm so impressed that the s21 is looking
so close on this
that's the thing that's crazy um oh man
i think personally i'm gonna go with
okay let me try to look okay no i'm not
gonna say anything i'm trying to look
i'm trying to look for any hints of
issues of blur
i don't i kind of like the one on the
right i like the depth of field and i
kind of like the
bokeh from that reflection there that's
true overall i just like it better
i don't know why i'm just gonna go with
the right i'm gonna go with the one on
the left
okay i have to i think this might be the
s21 i don't know what this little thing
right here is you see that darkness
yeah it looks like it might be some kind
of glue maybe it is
yeah i just like the white balance
better this looks too warm for me
but this is this is shockingly close
sony that's okay that's 21. i was right
you got the a1
dude 1200 bucks it's crazy no multiple
lenses
covered in 9 500. fortress shot right
here
of elon right away i'm going with the
left because like look at all the detail
in his hair
and like the colors really stand out
whereas the one on the right is kind of
flat
i think it's just a lot of these work
like the other portrait shot outside was
also overexposed
this is overexposed slightly overexposed
a1 again
well expected so far the 9 500
package is winning yeah and now this is
our first video so we're not taking
a look at just photo 8k video on both of
these
8k videos let's go ahead and play this
back
this is actually a very tough scenario
the background's super bright
you're walking yeah i'm i'm walking
jesus stabilization what is going on i
know i mean this has to be
the phone it has to be the phone but man
it doesn't look better that's good
that's a question i mean you could use a
gimbal i like the depth of field there
but like if you're not using a gimbal
this was like perfectly smooth
this would be the shot that you would
want and like
you know you still get the detail in the
sky which is super impressive dynamic
range and
this was actually s log three and i
graded it yeah
it's like in order to get the full
dynamic range but since you're walking
all that shake you know so i mean that
has to be the s21
yeah but which which one would you want
i mean i'd still go with that one
because
that one was just too shaky if you use
the gimbal i'd probably go with that but
it was too shaky all right so
i guess if it's for social media use and
you need ak
i would say this one yeah that is the
s21 ultra and i have to add in
the the previous 8k on the s20 looked at
garbage the 4k
looked better it was horrible they made
some massive improvements with the 8k
and the autofocus too they improved yep
all right we got another shot here
oh okay whoa what is going on i mean
this is a tough one
i can definitely tell which one is the
phone you know
and it's the one on the right because
you get the better dynamic range
but everything pops out more the green
color pops out more
it looks kind of like more sharp this
one just looks
too flat the dynamic range is bad
because of that i'm honestly going with
the one on the right really okay and i
know it's the phone too just this one's
so bland
and i guess we should add it's bland
people edit their photos
on cameras way more often than on their
phone so you could
you know do that but yes i guess you see
that difference
i'm voting for the left because you can
fix that you can add a little more
contrast it does look a little too flat
but with the blur here this was actually
a portrait shot i don't know if you
noticed i didn't want to say that
it messes up yeah it can't that is just
way too tough and
although it did the outside correctly so
i'm voting for the one on the left
s21 i get an a1 all right here we have a
bright shot in
full direct sunlight what do you think
man does this look like a 8 000
difference they're both so close
it's not an eight thousand dollar
difference no more than eight thousand
yeah i don't know but oh man uh let's
see
i think for this one i'm gonna go with
the left they're both very similar but i
don't like
how much contrast this has like too much
contrast like the
darks the blacks are getting crushed
like here and in the hair
even though the blur everything looks
good but i'm gonna go with this it's
more balanced
okay i'm going with you're trying to
convince me to change my mind i'm going
out the one on the right
i'm just shocked by like this was like i
had she had to close her eyes
yeah i had to count to five then she had
to open it and it did such a great job
with detail i like the brighter
highlights
i'm going for the right s21 and you get
an a1
a1 right and this is our second video
clip here
okay both 8k
and sorry about the show i honestly
didn't think there was gonna be that
much shake so this has
image stabilization built in um but
yeah it did not do a good job and i was
not trying to walk shaky or anything
else
yeah i mean i'm obviously going with the
left 100
just that shake is completely unusable
and there's no way you could ever use
that so yes so
a1 uh you got the s21 i'm voting s21 as
well
to be completely honest with you guys i
thought the 8k
was going to look a lot worse than it
did just like an s20 it was garbage
it was shaky the stabilization sucked on
the 8k before
so i thought it'd be more comparable but
it did a killer job even in this freeze
frame man like it's
very detailed surprisingly super
detailed so 8k
is no longer just a gimmick very good
take a look at that what do you think
well for this one i'm going with the
right
definitely everything's more detailed
sharp yeah and uh
there's a lot of noise here too on the
left so right for sure
i'm gonna go with the right as well
looks far better super good
that is the a1 and you guys see that is
a massive crop so this is a hundred and
eight megapixels
compared to 50 megapixels isn't
everything and this is
lens issues i think really lens softness
okay and same thing with noise when it's
taking a huge megapixel image
it doesn't do as much computational
stuff so it's cropped in yeah and 50
looks way more deep super clean
yeah and here we have an ultra wide
photo i don't know if i should say
anything else you can just guess it's
very difficult lighting
it's extremely difficult lighting like
extremely it's obvious which one's which
it's
uh this is obviously the s21 yes
i mean i would definitely go with this
absolutely
this is just everything's so blown out
it was extremely bright outside
yeah extremely dark underneath there
when i took the photo with s21
the whole sky was blown out worse than
this and then when i go into my the
photos app
in post all sudden and my mind was
shocked
and it's really good so yes that is the
a1 this is the s21 wow that's impressive
it looks crazy it looks good a little
bit
a little bit weird and this was actually
a raw photo
i let the camera take the exposure
itself and this one yeah
this is what this is what the jpeg
looked like
wow so well actually it was the heif
that's what it would have looked like
without editing
this other one is uh a raw so
now we have some more ak video okay
no shake this time we're looking at
detail i have lots of water here
i'm gonna go with the right um if if you
look at this bridge you can see much
more detail it's not soft like it is on
the left
and definitely in these rocks to see
more detail as well
i it's tough is it tough yeah i guess
i'll go with the right because there's
the highlights are a little bit brighter
it's not as flat of an image
yeah more contrast too that is the a1 so
when we don't have a shake
the a1 does look better which it should
so maybe instead of 9 500
i should add a gimbal yeah we need
more over over 10 over 10k but
that i was once again shocked by how
good the the 8k looks on there
selfie i think this is our first selfie
right right this one's really tough
because i like
how balanced one on the right is you
know especially with the background
not being blown out but the one on the
left because you're getting that depth
of field with the
the tree the branches being blurred out
and everything i don't know i kind of
like the one on the left
a little bit better i don't know it's so
tough i see what you're saying
it's tough i agree but i'm gonna go with
the one on the right
yeah just because i don't know like my
our faces pop out and to me that matters
a lot
even though it's a little too like the
background's a little too bright
this seems just a little bit too flat
and then of course dynamic range not
that it really matters in the shot like
this
but if i had to choose one to have for
to keep
it would be the one on the right okay
s21
a1 and we have
the courthouse castle yep
this one is definitely going to the left
you can see just so much more detail all
the
little bricks stones whatever very very
detailed compared to this looks like
it's kind of like
over contrast yeah noisy a1
versus s21 then this is with the crazy
most
most expensive zoom lens to zoom even
this far
that's where this was the tap of a
button yep
and we have our macro shots
oh man it's hard and i
i mean these points these are hard to
make it's very hard these are very hard
to make
and they're hard to choose but they're
hard to make oh this is really tough
um there's a couple of things i mean i
like how much depth of field there is
here the only downside is it's kind of
lacking it's either lacking
sharpness or it's slightly like out of
focus because of how
close you know how shallow the depth of
field is i think that might be it
because if you look yeah
yeah there's definitely some more in
focus and on the left the issue is it's
kind of overexposed for one
second issue is that you could see all
of the leaves in the back nothing stands
out
so because the one on the right stands
out really nice depth of field
i'm going to go with that i think okay
video you changed my mind did i
you changed i think you're absolutely
right i liked how the a lot more wasn't
focused no like
it's a little bit sharper i think
there's more sharpening added out of the
gate
but you're right it blends with the
background where this it pops
going for the right a1 okay
and we're getting into the nighttime
shot so let's see
what happens there definitely the one on
the right i mean it's just so much more
clean tons of noise it's all flat it's
all gray
i'm going with the right i agree now
which one do you think is which
i think the the s21 is the right because
it's night mode
it is knife mode kills it is yeah even
though this was a longer exposure but
with 50 megapixels there's a good amount
of noise that
it captures yes this stacks like nine
images
and does all the magic and this is
another video we only have two more
videos
uh how about i just play it yeah you
take a look
okay slow motion
let's see
that looks good definitely the one on
the right i mean just look how much more
detail it is like look at her hair
everything's more detailed and the one
on the left is just kind of blown out
in the autofocus yeah if you noticed
but like so many more things going for
the one on the right yeah super clean
so that's good a1 again
this is 4k 120 frames per second that's
so detailed 4k 120. yeah
and night mode shot it was super dark
yeah this lighting is from like across
the street there once again the right
it kills it you're right everywhere
you're right it's the right
kills that's 21. and
nighttime portrait you know what i don't
remember which one is which
okay this is hard i'm going for the one
on the right
once again because i like the contrast
the one on the left is very flat
once again i mean the bokeh looks nice
but she's flat i see some noise in there
um her hair doesn't look as detailed
the one on the right once again yeah i
would yeah i think maybe a little bit
too much contrast
a one this time one dang the bokeh
s21 bogus that looks so good i almost
thought
also there was the it was the opposite
because this looks realistic this almost
looks a little too fake
wow yeah okay
oh well this image got misaligned
nighttime shots guys what do you think
the world i mean obviously the one on
the top
yeah the bottle is just garbage man it's
just too
too bright a1 night mode doesn't always
get you where you want
yeah when you have tons of lights and
can i say that i did this three times
this photo
i tried touching on the brightest part
it didn't care it just
it wanted to give me this all right
another nighttime shot here so
i uh i mean i'm definitely going with
the one on the right because i'm on the
left you can see it's overexposed here
with the washington
water power and this was kind of a long
exposure which makes you think it was
the
the s21 because you know you had the
moving water so one of the right for
sure i think i like it and i'll say this
is kind of my fault i could have done a
longer exposure
maybe i would need to put it on a tripod
typically for that you'd want to do that
and that is the a1 um whereas this
it can take 20 images and choose the
five that work the best you know and
stack up
all right we got a selfie here all right
with this one
i'm gonna go with the one on the left
even though i do have that weird um
i don't know if that's artifacting noise
whatever this one has some too though
can you see that okay maybe it has a
little bit but still
here even though it doesn't look quite
as
bright and poppy i guess it looks more
like i like it it still looks more
natural this one just it just gets
overwhelmed by the lights in the
background
there's no depth of field and that light
right in the middle
yeah so yeah the one on the left still
and that is the a
one a one so i guess night mode just
overexposed
everything there wow and i gotta say it
is a pain taking selfies on a camera
like this
i'm holding it out i'm doing this whole
thing that's crazy
okay and we have this shot right here
what is this this is you this is your uh
can i say you're ready
this is your 108 megapixels right here
what oh this is cropped in right
this is 108 megapixels so bad look at
that noise and everything
i don't i don't know if you would want
to use that mode i guess now we learned
do not use the 108 megapixel mode at
night because it looks like garbage
so yeah right compared to 50. it's so
clean on the right
yep so a1 again and the very last
video clip and the last shot in general
we have some 8k
video it's just like when it's really
dark oh it was pretty dang dark
wow it wasn't that dark but i mean
obviously the right
i can't even see anything on the left
you can't so
uh yeah that is the sony a1 once again
you have you can kick up the iso
super high of the full frame sensor
whereas the ak looked great in the
daytime when it was super bright
looks sharp but when it's dark there's
no night mode for videos
all right well we have our results done
we have our results here
uh i haven't counted mine up you haven't
counted your guys yours up
go and pause the video count up all what
you uh what you chose we want to hear
your guys's opinion
and then go ahead and vote down below
all right guys make sure you guys voted
down below i'll start out
i have nine for the s21 and
16 for the a1 meaning it's not
9 9000 9500 package
is thankfully better than this 1200
phone with cameras and everything else
that fits in your pocket
good but what did you get i have eight
for the s21 ultra and
seven one extra point for the a1 so
so we want to hear your guys's opinions
what did you think about this you guys
saw all of those shots
i want to hear did you think it was
going to be this close
and i i for myself i did not i'm shocked
i'm shocked at how well that performed
because this a1 is like
groundbreaking the best of the best
that's like the best camera out there
that literally i don't even is it even
for sale yet right now it's for sale
yeah it's nobody does it earlier yeah
thank you sony
but yeah i'm really impressed by like in
the daytime how well the s21 ultra does
it's
that's shocking and we're sad about our
iphones
if you guys are behind if you guys
haven't seen this the
comparison against iphone 12 for max
we'll leave it right over there there's
a box
make sure to check it out click that
circle above if you guys want to
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this one we have a lot of great
content coming up you guys can help us
reach
600k which is our goal thank you for
watching this and max
and vadim and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video